cogs and dials across Europe
tick-tock towards brexit day 109 days
left to March the 29th the date we leave
with or without a deal but one famous
clock has stopped the scaffolded big
been a metaphor for the deadlocked
Parliament below it where the Prime
Minister has acknowledged her brexit
plan is jammed so what now
firstly she'll have to go back to
Brussels to negotiate Plan B the problem
is there are differing views in the
country and her own party on what she
should be asking for well I think that
the Prime Minister will want to have
further conversation Brussels there's an
EU council at the end of this week to
see whether in negotiation is possible
my instinct is that I don't think it is
going to be possible we have to have a
firm proposal we have to make sure that
we're going to move to a free trade
agreement a free trade area before we've
handed me money over throughout this
process it's been difficult for us
because we have set red lines and then
found that we can't really negotiate
with those red lines which is why my
argument is to make sure that we
consider every option on the table given
this is an irreversible decision for us
if the Prime Minister comes back with a
new deal there will still need to be a
vote and if she can't sell that time is
really running out
officially the government would then
have 21 days to outline a new way
forward but Parliament rises on December
the 20th MP's return on January the 7th
and may wish to amend plans further the
cutoff date for all of this is January
the 21st to give Parliament time to
implement legislation before Brett sit
down Christmas is a no-confidence vote
in the government by Labour but there'd
be unlikely to be successful because
they'd have to win over the DUP if they
managed it in the next 24 hours both
parties would then have 14 days to form
a government that could command a
majority in the Commons which takes us
to Boxing Day and if all that fails it's
a general election a five-week run would
probably ballot in mid-february it's
quite possible the Tories could submit
their 48 letters of no confidence in
their leader this week and if Theresa
May loses that vote expects a large
field of candidates trying to replace
her ballots amongst MPs could run into
early January then Tory members vote on
the final - that again brings us to
mid-february before it's sorted the
fastest referendum of recent times took
40 weeks so people's vote would run well
into next year we learned today that the
UK could cancel article 50 but if we
wanted to delay the brexit date say to
October we'd need a EU agreement when I
talk to you
negotiators what they say to me is we'll
agree to extend article 50 if there's a
good reason like if you want to have a
general election you won't have a
referendum but if the reason for the
extension is frivolous if the reason for
the extension is well the Tory party
needs to have a few weeks to work out
what it wants to do and have another de
Battlement within itself about way the
way for a brexit then they'll say no
if article 50 remains in place and we
run out of time for a deal there is only
one option left leave without a deal
Jason Farrell Sky News